meet the villagers that stand out our
conflict in the world war terrorism
climate chaos global warming social
injustice and and radical poverty and
the emergence of new diseases and
epidemics that have the potential to
wipe out civilization but all this I
believers has creative solutions I think
the biggest challenge for anybody is to
break out of a habit and the world is
entrenched in habits that are very
ancient and unless we change those
habits and the most important habit that
we have to change is the idea of me and
mine the idea that if I can just look
out for myself and not worry about the
other then I'll be okay but we want
because me and the other are
inextricably woven into the identity
that we call us and we have to get out
of the habit of thinking house versus
them at this moment the welfare of every
sentient life and every human being is
intimately tied into our own whether
United States
to get out of his meal of a habit of
belligerence unilateralism arrogance
domination imperialism and emotional
immaturity if the United States doesn't
do that it will become irrelevant in the
next 15 years I think the bring issues
of next presidential election is to
think totally out of the box instead of
saying can we win the war in Iraq the
question should be can we find a
creative solution which exposes our
vulnerability at the same time requests
the help of the international community
including the Iraqis or you know people
in the Islamic world we have to really
think of creative solutions for all the
problems instead of using words like war
on terrorism war on drugs war on AIDS
war on poverty let's understand that
creativity is the solution and that we
have to get out of our extreme
nationalism as well unfortunately you
know people don't realize what
nationalism is a very dangerous impulse
Einstein said nationalism is an
infantile disease it's the measles of
humanity nationalism is a sophisticated
form of tribalism and Rick from a great
psychologist said nationalism is our
form of incest it's our idolatry and
patriotism is a cult I think somebody
has to be brave enough risk enough to
tell the truth and not to worry about
you know whether they'll get the water
not a fair authentic then